اذا تحتدم الاشتباكات والمعارك في جنوب
العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم بين القوات
المسلحه السودانيه وقوات الدعم السريع
وافاد مراسل الجزيره بان اشتباكات عنيفه
تتركز في احياء الصحافه وجبر ودرجه الاولى
وقرب المدينه الرياضيه وقال القائد الثاني
لقوات الدعم السريع للجزيره ان هذه القوات
تتعرض حاليا لهجوم من مختلف الاتجاهات وهي
تتصدى له وقال مراسل الجزيره ان مختلف
انواع الاسلحه تستخدم في هذه الاشتباكات
التي يقول الجيش انها جاريه لاخراج قوات
الدعم السريع من هذه المناطق بشكل نهائي
كما قال ان مواطنين حاولوا الخروج من هذه
المناطق بسبب حده الاشتباكات
اكد قائد بالجيش السوداني سيطره الجيش على
مقر القياده العامه في الخرطوم وقال في
مقطع مصور ان الجيش سيظل يدافع عن السودان
وسيادته ولن يفرط في اي شبر من ارض
السودان ويظهر الفيديو الذي نشره الجيش
صورا قال انها الاحتفال عدد من الضباط
والجنود امام مقر القياده العامه للحرس
الرئاسي في الخرطوم
قال الجيش السوداني في بيان له ان قواته
تجاوزت مرحله الصمود والتحدي الى ما وصفها
بمرحله التنظيف التدريجي لبؤر وجود
الجماعات المتمرده حول العاصمه وقال ان
الشعب يعيش اوضاعا استثنائيه ستنجلي
بتكاتف الجيش والشعب كما لفت الى ان
الصعوبات الحاليه
يتشاركها المواطنون والجيش لتخليص البلاد
مما وصفه باسوء مظهر عسكري في تاريخ
السودان واتهم الناطق الرسمي باسم الجيش
السوداني ميليشيا الدعم السريع بانها تنهب
سيارات ومخازن الهلال الاحمر السوداني
بمنطقه بحر شمال الخرطوم